i find a lot of the sort of wilder stuff
that's going on really exciting and i'm
just really fascinated to see how it
pans out i think the the treatment i'd
put most in this category is cellular
reprogramming because
i often say it feels like it's fallen
through a wormhole from the future
so hello and welcome to the cheeky
science show where in this video i had
the great pleasure of speaking with
andrew still author of the book ageless
i'm full-time science writer and
presenter based in london
andrew previously obtained a phd in
physics from the university of oxford
before staring towards computational
biology
here we discuss some of the fascinating
discoveries in his book ageless and his
thoughts on how computational biology
can be applied to aging research
i hope you enjoy our conversation
oh hi andrew thank you for joining me
today and welcome to the shaky science
show right so great to have you on today
thanks for having me it's a pleasure i'm
looking forward to it thanks um so my
first question before we go into like um
the details of your book and your
interest in the aging research um his
first question is just um to get a
better understanding of your background
which i believe was a phd in physics so
i was just wondering like what initially
drew you to the area of physics and then
what kind of led you from physics into
the more computational biology routes
yeah it's been a bit of a journey and i
guess like an awful lot of scientists
actually my sort of science origin story
is back when i was my mom says about
seven years old i'd look up at the sky
i'd look at all the constellations up
there all the stars and you sort of
ponder my place in the universe and i
think about that age i decided i wanted
to be a theoretical astrophysicist and
slowly but surely my career has sort of
diverged away from this sort of
incredible abstract you know fascinating
big questions sort of end of science
into the more practical you know trying
to help people end of things so i ended
up as you say i did a degree and a phd
in physics um i worked on magnetism and
super conductivity during my phd but
toward the end of my phd i was trying to
look for a way that i could use my
career to make a difference in the world
one of the things i considered for
example was um becoming a climate
physicist which would have been a bit
more of a conventional transition trying
to use those skills you know to
understand and hopefully tackle the
problem of climate change
but at that time i started reading about
aging biology and actually what i
normally tell people which is a bit of
an oversimplification but not much of
one is that i changed career because of
a graph and that graph is the graph of
human mortality risk as associated with
age so obviously i think you know
everyone watching this channel will be
familiar with the fact that humans risk
of death doubles every eight years
and you know as a physicist you look at
that and you think wow um this is just
this staggering thing that applies
across human populations it applies
across time i can take basically any
human from any place on the earth at any
time in human history and their risk of
death will you know be different
depending when they lived but it'll
still have this same sort of ticking
clock this doubling every eight years
and so you look at that as a physicist
you're trained to see you know see
patterns in incredibly complicated
phenomena and you think wow
you know is there something going on
here inside our biology that's causing
this fundamental you know incredibly
constant ticking clock and if we could
go in there and intervene
could we do something about it and so
then i started reading about you know
things like calorie restriction and
rapamycin experiments just getting quite
big around that time cause that was on
the interventions testing program
results who just came out about that
there seemed to be loads of exciting
stuff going on but i did sort of have
this niggling doubt at the back of my
mind i stopped studying biology formally
at gcse so that's 16 years old for
anyone who's not in the uk
and you know obviously if i'm scratching
my head you know maybe i'm a physicist
in the classic physicist thing of
looking at a field and thinking we can
just go in there and nail that we can
just you know draw a graph and
understand the whole thing actually you
know maybe it's just a bit more
complicated than that and that's why
biologists aren't concentrating on it as
much as i perhaps thought they should um
so i decided i was going to try and
become some kind of biologist and there
are various different ways as a
physicist you can try and apply those
skills to biology
a common one which i've got a few
friends who've actually done this route
you can take the very practical lab
bench experimental skills and become
something like a microscopist so you can
use all the optics that you learn as a
physics undergrad and during your phd
and use it to develop new microscope
techniques or something like that
and i sort of thought really you know
what i want to understand are the big
biology questions and although obviously
it's hugely hugely important because
these new microscopy techniques and so
on allow us to do entirely new kinds of
science they allow us to literally see
things we couldn't see before and
discover new stuff as a result i wanted
to do something that gave me a bit more
of an overview and so that's why i
thought the computational biology and
genomics and that kind of thing was a
bit you know more than each for me you
know you can still use the analytical
skills obviously i'd learned a bit of
coding as part of my phd as well um and
take all of those skills and apply them
to biological data instead of physics
data and then i just felt that would
give me a bit more of a sort of
bird's-eye view of the field and
hopefully you know try and understand
whether aging was indeed something we
could do something about and if so you
know how and try and contribute to that
that's a really good answer and i was
actually going to say um i'm actually a
bit jealous that you've done a phd in
undergrad in physics because obviously i
haven't done physics since a-level and
obviously there's so much overlap
between the different disciplines of
science even in biology there's no um
processes such as mechanical
transduction and electrical signaling
and actually having that kind of physics
understanding um could be really useful
to actually understand some of these
more complex phenomenons in biology so
um i was just wondering is there any any
way you can elaborate on how you think
your skill sets in physics help you to
apply that to biological research
i think at the moment we're at a point
where um actually a lot of the physics
stuff is a bit bleeding edging biology
and i think quantum biology is a really
good example i think it's gonna become
abundantly clear over the next you know
five ten years that quantum processes
are going on in biology because
evolution has had billions of years to
optimize our enzymes and all different
stuff going on inside ourselves at an
incredibly detailed level it'll be
frankly astonishing if it wasn't using
quantum mechanics on some level to
optimize all those different processes
but the trouble is we are right at the
bleeding edge of whether that's actually
useful i mean are we going to find out
that some quantum biological phenomenon
is a 10th or 11th or 12th hallmark of
aging i guess we'll find out but at the
moment i think that like i say a lot of
the physics stuff is about technique
development and actually you know i
ended up basically not using my physics
knowledge at all i think it's it's quite
cool just to have a really general
grounding in science and you know
another thing i could have gone into
because of my magnetism and
superconductivity background it's like
mri imaging which obviously depends on
these enormous magnets to you know build
detailed pictures of what's going on
inside the human body i think it is
really important just to have a bit more
of a general scientific background to
understand you know how different fields
work and perhaps just look at look at
things with a different perspective
because i think you know although i
didn't have that biology training
perhaps in some ways i didn't have that
baggage either so it allows you to look
at things in a different way so i don't
really think there's like a simple
formula i certainly wouldn't recommend
if you you know if your passion is aging
biology i wouldn't recommend that
everyone go away and do a physics phd
first it's a bit of a securities root
but i think those things you know having
a fresh perspective on stuff can
definitely be an advantage as well
well said and so to go to your your book
ageless i'm going to take one quote from
it which i think um kind of hints at
your more physics um understanding which
is you describe um life is under no
thermodynamic obligation to age um so i
was just wondering could you break down
that statement for us
yeah i think there are two ways of
looking at that so people when they talk
about aging i think even when you think
about aging we often think of it as just
a natural process of falling apart and
you can really see why this would be the
science of thermodynamics was born in
the sort of 19th century primarily
people were looking at steam engines
they were trying to understand the
actual physical processes going on
inside them and you know machines like
steam engines they rust they decay
machines in factories they wear out as
different components get you know
basically friction rubbed against each
other if you don't lubricate them
properly etc and it just really seems
like you know why would humans be any
different from the machines that we can
build
well the answer is of course they're
biological and so they've got these
incredibly complicated self-repair
mechanisms going on inside them but it
might be that perhaps there is this
problem of thermodynamics so the second
law of thermodynamics is that entropy
will tend to increase what's entropy
well it's that's that's a whole sort of
uh video interview in itself but entropy
basically is a measure of disorder it's
a measure of things becoming more
disordered you're going from an ordered
state into one where things are a bit of
a mess and so the second law states that
entropy will always increase with time
and what that means therefore is that
you expect an ordered physical system
you know beautifully ordered human body
for example just holding myself up here
is the most beautifully ordered example
of humanity by doing the hand gesture
but my body should you know under the
second law of the thermodynamics you
might expect it to gradually deteriorate
because at some point those repair
processes aren't going to be able to
keep up with with basically the you know
endless march of thermodynamics the
problem is that people who say that
neglect the second half of the second
law which is the entropy tends to
increase in a closed system and what
does a physicist mean by a closed system
they mean a system that can't import an
energy and can't export any of our
entropy or disorder into its environment
and clearly living things aren't such a
system you know we can eat food which is
obviously the way that we get our energy
or if you're a plant you can
photosynthesize you can use the light
from the sun to you know to generate
energy yourself and then we can export
that entropy through a variety of
different means that i won't go into too
much detail about into our environment
so we can get rid of that disorder we
can get rid of waste effectively and so
there's no sort of physics reason why it
would be that we should age and so that
sort of demolishes that argument just by
looking at it from a purely theoretical
standpoint i think the thing that's more
compelling to me though actually is then
to go to the biology um because you know
you do get to a point where you don't
care about the physics if you've already
got a biological example where this
doesn't happen i already mentioned that
humans risk of death doubles every eight
years there are loads of creatures out
there whose risk of death doesn't double
at all it stays flat when they become
adults and the reason there's a tortoise
on the cover of my book is that giant
tortoises are one such creature they've
got a risk of death that doesn't change
with time they don't get any more frail
depending on how old they are uh they
even stay reproductively active until
they're late in life so in a very real
sense they don't age so not only is not
aging not against the laws of physics
because it doesn't defy entropy it's
also not against the laws of biology
because we can point to tortoises and
salamanders and fish and naked mole rats
all these animals out there in the world
that don't seem to age either and so i
think there's this sort of i can
understand where this fatalism comes
from because it does seem that aging is
inevitable and we aren't really exposed
to these creatures you know that there
are obviously a handful of people who
have a pet tortoise but they probably
haven't done a detailed demographic
study of a thousand pet tortoises in
order to come to these kinds of
conclusions so we now actually assume
that everything ages but actually it's
not that inevitable at all that's i
think one of the most exciting things
about this field
exactly that's really well said so
talking more generally about your book
what kind of motivated you to write the
book in the first place
i was inspired to write the book
actually by my work as a biologist
because i found that a lot of the
biologists i interact with during my
work um i'd often know more than they
did about aging biology that isn't
because i'm some kind of genius you know
again not wanting to sound like a
physicist who's barging into the field
and feels like they suddenly know
everything the reason was that you know
i'd meet people with incredible degrees
from incredible universities and they'd
never have had a lecture on aging
biology there's not a single page in a
lot of biology textbooks about aging and
that's just sort of staggering to me
because it's one of the most universal
processes we've just heard it's not
quite universal but a huge number of
species age and it's a you know
evolution is perhaps the most universal
phenomenon in biology but aging is
definitely up there as one of the others
and i think there's this sort of strange
phenomenon that aging has been quite a
small field historically perhaps because
of what we were just talking about
actually because people have thought is
this inevitable process of falling apart
that we can't really do anything about
maybe it's just too complicated for
biologists to take a serious interest in
and because the field is small
historically other fields have been
larger it sort of creates this vicious
cycle and you find that you know if
you're never lectured about aging
biology you're never going to get
excited about it so you're not going to
apply for a phd in it and even if you
want to apply for a phd in it there just
aren't that many labs with phds to apply
for and that means that you know when
you get to the end of your actual phd in
cancer research or in virology or
whatever it is what are you going to do
you've already got a few papers you've
already got a bit of experience in that
field you're going to go on you know
become another cancer researcher or
another virologist yourself and that
means that when you're lecturing your
students and inspiring the next
generation you're not going to be
telling them all about aging biology are
you going to be telling them about your
field of expertise and so on and so on
this sort of perpetuates this cycle
which means that aging biology and i
assume therefore other neglected fields
of science remain neglected purely
because they never quite gain this
critical mass and i really think that's
a i sort of diagnosed that pathology and
i thought that i want to write a book
for a variety of reasons
um basically to convince lots and lots
of people about how exciting this field
is and obviously among those people i
count the general publics i think that
people just don't understand this
science they think it's some kind of
sci-fi kooky weirdness when you talk to
them about it um in that same sort of
category i put politicians and
policymakers that people are funding the
science they don't realize you know
every politician knows a friend or a
relative who's died of cancer so cancer
research gets comparatively within
science a you know larger slice of the
pie perhaps whereas
people don't think you can die of aging
they don't see cancer as a disease
caused by the aging process so again
you've got to try and communicate to
that group you know what aging biology
is all about but then beyond that i
needed to communicate to the biologists
as well i need to show them that this is
a legit field this isn't some again some
sort of cranky snake oil you know people
trying to live forever nonsense it's
actually genuinely hard science that you
know that works we've got you know
dozens and dozens of labs around the
world showing really promising results
in this now and actually i i then went
on to marry a doctor and i found that
doctors also don't know much about aging
biology you know to the extent that
they're taught about aging uh when they
have their lectures on aging it's about
well it's very complicated to care for
these geriatric patients they've often
got multiple different diseases so you
have to think about that there are
social problems because you know perhaps
they're living alone at home and so that
complicates things they're taking you
know five or ten different drugs so if
you want to prescribe them a new drug
you've got to check how those drugs are
going to interact
but nothing on the fact that you know
during my wife's career she's quite
likely to have to prescribe people these
first generation of anti-aging drugs
it's not wildly outside the bounds of
possibility and yet when she first met
me i was crazy she thought you know what
what is this sort of mad kooky sci-fi
anti-aging stuff and so in order to get
the message out to that whole range of
different audiences i just thought i've
got to try and do something about this
and that's what made me decide to write
a
book
yeah well said and i have to say having
read your book is very well explained
and i think it's very accessible to
people from any like background
knowledge so yeah congratulations to you
for that
and so in your book you discuss a lot of
uh theories of aging and to begin with
you speak a lot about the different
evolutionary theories of why we my age
um so i was just wondering like
having done all this background reading
to write your book what theory do you
think makes most sense to you at the
moment to explain why it's why that
humans age compared to these other
organisms you've discussed that seem to
not show um
phenotypes of aging
i think the most important thing to
remember about the evolution of aging is
the sort of strange paradox of its
center which is that the reason that
animals die of aging is because
ultimately they die of other things so
to sort of unpack what that means if you
find yourself in a very very high risk
environment let's imagine you're an
animal like a mouse and mice live you
know maybe six months or a year in the
wild so they've got very short lifespans
compared to an animal like a human
what that means you know basically
they're at high risk they've got cats
chasing after them all the time they can
get infectious diseases they're tiny
little animals so they can literally
just die of exposure it's called you
know they can get so cold on a winter's
night they just freeze to death and so
there are loads of different ways that a
mouse can meet a sticky end and so if
your evolution you know looking at this
scenario and trying to design a mouse's
sort of reproductive strategy you're
going to say
make a lot of babies and make them as
fast as possible so that your genes have
been passed on to the next generation
you have to make lots of babies because
lots of them are going to die in
horrible ways as well unfortunately
and so ultimately their reproductive
strategy is sort of have a lot of kids
and have them fast
and if that comes at the expense of
lifespan you know say that means that
they put a bit more energy into
reproducing or growing more quickly and
a bit less energy into creating
incredibly robust anti-cancer defenses
for example that are going to allow a
mouse at the age of two and a half to
not get a particular tumor well they're
just not going to bother with that are
they because they'd rather spend that
energy on reproducing because all the
mice in the wild are already going to be
dead by the time they get to the age
when they're going to be experiencing
age related problems
so that's sort of one side of the coin
and that's why the evolution of aging
this sort of drive to to not bother with
any kind of um long-term preservation
strategy evolves in animals that have a
naturally short lifespan for other
reasons because they have you know
external causes of mortality if we then
look at the other end of the scale a
nice example this is bats so bats
they're also you know they're mammals
they're quite closely related to mice
and this all evolutionary tree but the
key difference between a bat and a mouse
even though they're about the same size
as well a bat can obviously fly and it's
not just because flying is brilliant
that these things live a lot longer but
if you look in look out out in nature
then a bat can live to maybe 40 years i
think is their record i think it might
be 41 years old so why is it that bats
can live so much longer it's because
they're in a much safer environment
precisely because they can fly they've
got far fewer predators and so you know
that that means that they can afford to
put more energy into getting rid of
cancer into you know trying to keep keep
their bodies running for a much much
longer period of time and that entirely
changes their evolutionary strategy and
this manifests in a few different ways
it can manifest by
something called mutation accumulation
theory which is something that happens
um over evolutionary time where
mutations that are really bad in late
life can accumulate in an animal like a
mouse but a bat would de-accumulate
those mutations it will try and you know
get rid of anything that might kill it
you can then have um
unfortunately all that
all the ideas in aging biology aging
evolution have really really terrible
names um perhaps one of the most
explanatory theories is this thing
called antagonistic pliotropy
so let's unpack that antagonistic
obviously means that these things pull
in different directions and plyotropy is
the word that biologists give when a
gene has more than one characteristic so
you know so it can do different things
at different times or in different
situations and so that that then means a
gene that might be useful for gearing up
rapidly to reproduce in youth actually
causes some kind of problem later in
life and that's you know again it really
makes sense for the mice they might have
some gene that makes them grow more
quickly but makes cancer more likely as
they get older and so again you can see
this antagonistic thing the player
should be the gene behaves differently
depending on which part of the life the
mouse is in
and then
finally uh the other theory that i
discussed in the book is this thing
called disposable soma which is just the
idea that again they've all got awful
names disposable obviously means what it
means soma means the sort of body and
that's just the sort of um the
biologist's way of saying evolution
doesn't care about you it cares about
your genes being passed on to the next
generation so again if you're
apportioning energy between looking
after your body and looking after the
next generation well most the time
particularly in a dangerous environment
you're going to put it towards um
towards the next generation rather than
yourself which sounds all very
altruistic but ultimately of course
leads to us aging so how is it given all
of these things i've just described
three different mechanisms by which
animals can evolve in order to age and
it's not really on purpose it's sort of
an accidental byproduct of the fact they
get killed by other things but
nonetheless how do you animals that
don't i think it really varies depending
on their reproductive strategy
i think the clearest example of this is
in fish so i just mentioned that you
know mice love to have loads and loads
of kids when they're young but fish have
a very very different life cycle and
that's to say that a huge amount of the
reproduction by fish is done by massive
old fish and there's a great acronym for
this it's buffs which is big old fat
fertile female fish let me get that
right
and these fish they're massive
underwater matriarchs basically they
produce far far more eggs than uh
younger female fish the eggs are of
higher quality so they're more likely to
grow up into healthy fish themselves and
that means that a huge fraction of the
population's reproduction is done by
sort of this comparative handful of
really old female fish so evolution
suddenly has a huge incentive to make
sure that old female fish don't just die
of cancer or die of something else wants
to carry on you know keeping them alive
and all that they can carry on churning
out babies so again it just completely
changes the calculus and is obviously
scientists are slightly squirming in
their seat now because i'm giving
evolution a sort of a motive i'm saying
evolution wants this and wants that but
you can see in that situation why
evolution would want to keep that older
fish alive and depending on your life
course evolution doesn't care how long
you live evolution will do whatever it
does whatever it can to maximize the
propagation of your genetic material
onto the next generation and so if that
in the case of the fish means that you
might become negligibly senescent you
might even become negatively senescence
you might have a reducing chance of
death with time if that's what evolution
thinks is important on the other side of
the coin if you're a mouse and you're in
a really dangerous environment you're
going to crank out kids and you're going
to age very rapidly so i think basically
evolution doesn't care how long you live
it'll just try and maximize the number
of kids you have and unfortunately that
means that we are
one of those animals that does age
yeah well said i was actually gonna ask
you about the buffs because that was
something i hadn't learned about before
and it's kind of fascinating to see
examples where you seem to get promotion
to just um enable to increase fertility
but also to um reduce signs of aging so
that these um older fish can also remain
reproductive as well so that's obviously
a really interesting example and i think
understanding different organisms in
general is very useful because we can
always use insights from different
species to develop even human therapy
sex um so kind of shifting gears more to
the i guess the molecular underpinnings
of why we age and how we can do
something about it
you mentioned a nice example in your
book about uh lipofruskin and um
and how maybe it felt like a question um
you mentioned examples i say life
effusion but again it's one of those
words you know you you read it and you
almost never actually say it
that's right yeah so we can go with one
or the other i'm happy
um but you mentioned how there's
actually some enzymes so this is
something that accumulates in lysosomes
but it's something that our bodies can't
naturally degrade we have no enzymatic
activity to do it but there's been some
recent research that you describe and
we'll let you explain it in more detail
but it's the idea that we can
effectively use information and
um biology biology from different
organisms to help uh treat aging and
humans
yeah and i think there are just some
really fascinating examples of trying to
draw in enzymes because there obviously
are creatures that can break down like a
few sin somewhere because otherwise you
know with the entire surface of the
earth would basically be just covered in
huge huge piles of stuff but something
must be degrading in the environment so
we can look to things like soil dwelling
bacteria that might be able to degrade
it i think the one that i found most
fascinating this i'm not sure this is
technically lipofusine but it's about um
oxidized cholesterol that builds up in
the lysosomes of um cells that are part
of atherosclerosis when you're you know
basically they're furring of your
arteries as you get older the
cholesterol gets gobbled up by these um
by these immune cells but unfortunately
they can't really do anything with it
they just tuck it away in their
lysosomes it often gets oxidized it
often gets all kinds of other reactive
stuff stuck all over it and we were
scratching our heads about how on earth
we could possibly you know get rid of
this stuff it's very very hard to
degrade which is obviously why they
can't do it and what the researchers
found was there's there's been this
long-standing mystery about how
tuberculosis bacteria survive hiding out
inside immune cells potentially for
years or even decades because
tuberculosis is an infection that can go
dormant and then come back out at times
of stress and what they found was that
the tuberculosis bacteria were surviving
by using some kind of cholesterol
metabolism so they were effectively
digesting the cholesterol they found
inside these immune cells and so what
the scientists did was they extracted
obviously the enzyme that was
responsible inserted it into some cells
in the lab and they found that it did
indeed successfully break down this
oxidized cholesterol the only problem
was that the byproduct it created during
that reaction was itself toxic to the
cell so it wasn't a sort of long-term
solution but you can see how with a bit
of tweaking that's something that we
could use to attack the root cause of
atherosclerosis which is you know the
leading cause of heart disease basically
is the cause of heart disease um and
that's really exciting because the way
that we currently deal with heart
disease is just to try and reduce the
level of cholesterol in the blood which
does slow down the accumulation of these
plaques but can never ultimately stop
them but if this can go in there and
clear out the stuff that's causing these
all these immune cells to die and
causing these plaques to form in the
first place then you know that's one of
the dreams of aging biology you know
aging researchers to go in there and
actually solve these problems before
they accumulate to the point where they
cause disease rather than just slowing
these things down so i think this is one
of the more sort of exciting but
speculative areas of research that i
talk about in the book and i really hope
we can
sort of take some insights from other
species and crack it yeah so you raised
a really interesting point there that
there are kind of i guess two main
strategies for trying to treat aging one
is trying to
the more like um preventative strategy
to target the root cause and prevent the
i guess the bad of things from happening
and then the alternative strategy is to
kind of clear away the damage that's
already accumulated
um and so i was wondering if you could
maybe talk more about the latter
strategy as do do you think that that's
probably the more likely um therapeutic
outcome we'll see first before we see
these more preventative strategies
i think it's an interesting question and
i think that often it's um it's perhaps
overplayed in the sense that there are
there are maybe some things that fall
really clearly into one category or
another but there are lots of things
that seem to probably do both like if
you think about rapamycin this is
something that might be characterized as
something that just slows down the aging
process it's a drug that goes in it it
clogs up an enzyme that effectively um
is part of the response to calorie
restriction and we know that if animals
calorie restrict if they eat a lot less
they can live a lot longer and they can
do so in good health so by jamming up
this particular enzyme it tricks your
cells into thinking that you're eating
far far less than you are but in doing
so therefore activates some of those
longevity pathways that seem to be
activated through calorie restriction
and you might think oh you know
therefore what you're doing calorie
restriction doesn't allow animals to
live forever it just slows down their
aging it doesn't make them negligibly
senescent at all
so um you know maybe that is just a drug
that slows down aging but actually
rapamycin seems to have some effect on
cellulosin essence as well it seems to
get rid of senescent cells and you might
class getting rid of senescent cells as
one of these sort of damage repair type
therapies because you're taking these
senescent cells that accumulate in your
body over time and clearing them out so
i think you know while there's sometimes
seem to be this battle between those two
factions i think often it's not quite as
clear-cut as you know proponents might
suggest and actually of course um you
know it's also the case that even
researching things that you might think
only slow down the aging process and
perhaps you don't think that's as
beneficial that can throw up insights
into which hallmarks are being affected
it can you know what's accumulating more
rapidly and more slowly in this case
raging has been slowed down so it's
really not clear to me exactly how we
should be approaching the funding
because we just don't know what's the
most exciting thing at the moment
yeah well said i'm so speaking more
about i guess like why we age in general
like what do you what would be your main
contributors to the aging process or do
you think it is more a holistic effect
of multiple different processes
occurring
i think we're probably going to find
that it is a really holistic thing a
massive interconnected tangled you know
chaotic web of nonsense going inside our
bodies basically i think it's good to
break it down to hallmarks or pillars or
you know types of damage or whatever it
is that you're trying to do in order to
help come up with some kind of
conceptual framework and i think that
what
you know the results in the lab show
that we're going to actually potentially
have some quite large successes just
going after single hallmarks i'm really
quite excited by the fact that you can
give mice analytic drugs you can clear
out their senescent cells a single
hallmark of aging and it seems to impact
basically the whole of their biology in
terms of aging it seems to turn back
that you know the whole of their aging
clock it makes them live longer it makes
them have less disease it makes them
less frail it makes them less
cognitively i can't say that i'm not
less cognitively impaired right so i'm
starting to suffer from that a little
bit myself
and it also you know just makes them
look great i was a computational
biologist i've never dealt with mice in
the lab but mice that have had senescent
cell treatment they just look fantastic
they've got much better effects and you
know it's really going after the
cosmetic stuff as well which you know
unfortunately is going to get a certain
certain sections of the population
excited perhaps more so than the medical
side of things but nonetheless you know
going after the single hallmark has this
huge collection of benefits and it might
be that going after you know two or
three of the hallmarks or two or three
different processes has a synergistic
effect so you know has an effect that's
greater than the sum of its parts it
might be that some things have an effect
that's less than the sum of their parts
to effectively duplicate duplicating
efforts somehow
but ultimately and i talk about this
right at the end of the final sort of
science chapter of the book um i think
the way that we're going to really nail
aging is going to be by understanding a
sort of systems biology model of it
because i think that i mean and you can
already see this actually in the
discussion around students in cells
although senescent cells were first
named because they looked like old cells
they were cells that divided so many
times that they didn't you know weren't
able to divide anymore and that's why
they were thus christened we now
understand that senescent cells are a
vital part of development they're used
in the developing embryo to fashion
certain parts of your body they're using
wound healing and that's again sort of a
place where you want fresh tissue to
grow back and senescent cells secrete
these factors that cause cells to grow
um they seem to be implicated in some
way in the in the the growth of cancers
as well so again that's sort of a growth
related thing um so it's clear that sort
of senescent clapped out old isn't
necessarily the right way to think about
them and you know you see all these
arguments about how do we define a
senescent cell you know you can say it's
a cell that doesn't divide anymore but
is it a cell that's p16 positive is it a
cell that um is positive for the
celestions associated with
galactose is it i think you know there
are all these various ideas
galactose this is exactly your field
isn't it so i'll take any corrections
you're offering me um so if you know is
it positive for these various markers um
i suspect none of these will actually be
appropriate for what is a senescent cell
and
we'll probably have to come up with some
complicated composite marker it might be
that we end up taking out you know the
optimal for aging uh delay might be to
take out an entirely different subset of
cells which somewhat overlaps with what
we currently call senescence cells but
it's actually somewhat something else it
might be different in different parts of
the body
and i just think that is ultimately the
way we're probably going to end up
solving this problem because it can't be
as simple as you know just taking out
one particular class of cell and one
particular molecule and everything's
sorted or you feel like biology you know
evolution might have managed to do that
with a little bit more reason in
creatures out there in the wild so i
think the ultimate solution is going to
be a sort of big holistic systems
biology um you know
load of chaos in some ways but what's
more optimistic than that in the short
term is that we do have these treatments
you can do interventions in in the lab
and they can have dramatic effects on
the lifespan of mice the health of mice
most importantly um even though you only
seem to be doing one single thing
so my hope is that you know we can sort
of use the knowledge that we gain from
giving people these sort of laser guided
just senescent cells or just telomeres
or just whatever it is treatments and as
we understand how that interacts with
their aging more broadly we can start to
intervene in a slightly more intelligent
way and hopefully you know address
multiple hallmarks and eventually all
the hallmarks at once
yeah well simon i completely agree about
the whole system's biology approach um
and so you've mentioned certainlytics
but what kind of other uh strategies
from obviously writing your book do you
think are most promising or seem most
exciting at the moment for training
agent
i think there's a real range and i'm
excited about them all for sort of quite
different reasons this analytics i
really feel like are the most exciting
in the sort of near term for what i'd
call sort of a real
hallmarks based anti-aging treatment
because you know we've got results in
mice that show all these exciting things
i just talked about we've got human
trials going on for these drugs now
because some of them are pre-existing
approved drugs that have been approved
for different conditions so it's
something that we can extend into humans
um these trials at the moment are
obviously for specific diseases where we
know senescent cells are a problem but
hopefully if the drugs are effective so
obviously if they help with those
diseases but most importantly if they're
safe we could then think about rolling
them out to people who haven't got some
you know such severe problems and
eventually if they're safe enough we
could start thinking about rolling them
out preventatively you know maybe you're
just 60 or 65 so if you've accumulated
deficient cells that's worth giving you
one of these things preventatively and
if all goes well with that you know we
could easily have semalytics in
hospitals in the next few years for
specific conditions if those clinical
trials work and then it's not hard to
imagine that you know maybe five maybe
ten years after that we could start be
thinking about giving them out
preventatively and that really is i
think the ultimate sort of paradigm
shift in terms of the way that we
practice medicine so that's something
i'm very excited about for that sort of
variety of reasons i've just mentioned
um the sort of near-term stuff that's
less exciting in terms of the big
picture but probably more exciting in
terms of breaking the ground and the
things like metformin and rapamycin i've
already mentioned these you know
existing drugs that we think might be
able to slow down the aging process and
there's this trial i'm sure a lot of
your viewers have heard of the tame
trial in the u.s where they can actually
a proper randomized trial trying
metformin to see if it really does slow
down the aging process or if the sort of
hints we've got so far have maybe been
experimental artifacts and that you know
the the people who are doing tame even
they aren't necessarily that you know
this isn't going to double human
lifespan if net forming doubled human
lifestyle we'd know about it already but
the fact is it's going to lay the
regulatory groundwork that allows us you
know in the past we've only found it
easy to approve drugs that are against
specific medical they call them
indications in the jargon of regulation
um so specific diseases basically cancer
diabetes whatever it is
and if they can lay the groundwork with
that study and show firstly show
regulators that this is a thing that we
can do we can give people you know
people who would currently classify as
healthy a drug to prevent them becoming
unhealthy and also just show the public
and policymakers that we can develop
drugs that slow down aging i think
that's a really exciting thing even if
it isn't necessarily going to result in
the biggest breakthrough
um in the longer term i
i find a lot of the sort of wilder stuff
that's going on really exciting and i'm
just really fascinated to see how it
pans out i think the treatment i put
most in this category is cellular
reprogramming because i often say it
feels like it's fallen through a
wormhole from the future because we've
got this sort of collection of four
genes they were originally discovered by
yamanaka who was looking for a way to
turn you know adult body cells into a
stem cell and he was interested in those
stem cells because they can then turn
into any other kind of cell he wasn't
looking for something that could turn
back the sort of biological aging clock
but what we've since discovered is that
these four genes almost as a side effect
of that process
do indeed turn back the aging in those
cells and they do so in a surprisingly
you know wide widespread way they they
de-age whole you know they de-age their
what's called the epi
what's called the epigenetic clock this
measure of you know how old things how
old the cells are looking that way they
can make the mitochondria behave in a
more youthful way and there are just
loads and loads of changes that are
going on and now we've even shown that
you can um give these things to mice and
as long as you only turn them on
intermittently and therefore don't cause
the cells to go all the way back to
becoming a stem cell you seem to be able
to make those mice healthier so it's an
exciting result but the real question
for me and the reason i say it feels
like it's falling through a wormhole in
the future is you know can we can we
scratch our heads and like find a way to
turn this into a therapy that we can
actually give to humans in anything like
the near term because obviously gene
therapies are starting to come online
now we've got the first of those being
approved in the clinic for again for
specific conditions for people who are
willing to take a punt on something
experimental um but i'm certainly not
going to be lining up to have the
yamanaka factors injected into me
anytime soon so the question is you know
can we find a safer way to do this can
we identify some genes that perhaps you
know the amino factors they're these
skeleton keys inside the cell they
perform such a huge range of changes can
we find some that are a little bit more
targeted and can just address the sort
of aging aspect of this without changing
the nature of ourselves and potentially
putting us at risk of cancer and stuff
like that or you know ideally speaking
could we find a drug that can awaken
whatever process this is and you know
it would be ideal if this could be taken
as a pill rather than something more
exotic so the real question with those
kinds of therapies is you know can we
come up with a way of turning them from
this idea that works in cells in a dish
works in mice in the lab perhaps but can
we get it to a point where we can you
know consider safely deploying that in
human patients so there's this real
range of excitement from the very sort
of pragmatic near-term stuff to the
incredible sort of stuff that's on the
horizon the question is can we get that
stuff on the horizon a little bit closer
to actual practice
exactly and i agree i also think
cellular programming is also really
exciting um in particular stem cell
therapies and so you mentioned in the
book in a bit more detail about the
different potential therapies and so why
do you think we'd see stem cells being
used first
sorry so that again um why do you think
we'd see stem cell therapies being used
first like in the clinic if they ever
get like safety approval
i think
we're probably going to see them being
used again in cases and a lot of these
will be aging related this is one of the
parts of the book where i was more
excited because the developments weren't
going on so much as a sort of accidental
side effect of looking into other things
a lot of the diseases of aging are
caused by loss of cells of one kind or
another i think the two things that are
most advanced in the clinic at the
moment are stem cell therapies against
parkinson's disease and this honestly
really shocked me quite how long ago we
were doing this the first stem cell
therapies against parkinson's so
parkinson's is this disease where you
basically lose control of your motor
function gradually because of death of a
particular kind of neuron in a
particular part of the brain and because
it's this very specific type of cell in
a very specific localized region
scientists thought you know can we
replace those cells and thereby you know
give people a bit of their lives back
and actually scientists in sweden first
tried transplanting stem cells into
parkinson's patients in the late 1980s
so it's not like this is some wild
cutting-edge technology that you know we
just developed last year this has got a
really really long pedigree
and um what they found was you know they
were doing these experiments using um
cells that were extracted from fetuses
and they had to do this incredibly
complicated procedure pulling out this
tiny little ball of cells i think
smaller than the size of a pinhead from
a fetus that was maybe a couple of
centimeters long at that stage in
development then they'd culture those in
the lab and inject them into parkinson's
patients and it was a very very small
number of people right you know as a
handful of patients but they showed
these remarkable results and there's
been this ongoing controversy because
the that number of patients was so small
it was then
then some labs in the us attempted to
replicate it and they didn't quite
manage and the labs in sweden hit back
that they hadn't been doing the
technique correctly and you know had
therefore that was what the problem was
there's clearly still a bit of
excitement about this because there's a
massive study going on in europe at the
moment across different um hospitals all
over the continent trying to replicate
these results again in a much more
rigorous way across you know for a whole
variety of different locations and
actually i think the results of that i
do out pretty soon and not only that at
the same time we've got this huge
advance because of that discovery by
yamanaka that we can make these uh
pluripotent stem cells we don't have to
you know go on this sort of scavenger
hunt through tiny little fetuses that's
incredibly complicated and obviously you
know some people have ethical problems
with we can generate these cells from
other people's adult cells or even the
patient's own adult cells and turn them
into whatever kind of cell we want
including the cells that are lost in
this particular part of the brain in
parkinson's so i think that you know
potentially obviously stem cell therapy
feels like it's it's been on the horizon
for quite a number of years now but it
really does feel like the
parkinson's that's starting to come
together and the other place that i
think there is there are some really
advanced trials is looking at
age-related macular degeneration so
that's the most common form of blindness
in older people it's when you're macular
which is part of the retina the back of
your eye starts to degenerate as you get
older um again there are some really
cool stem cell experiments going on in
japan um there was this incredibly
detailed um
very practical safety study that was
done in pigs in the u.s and pigs have
just chosen because they're quite
anatomically and biologically close to
us in this particular situation where
they tried extracting stem cells from
genuine old donors so old human donors
to make it as realistic as possible and
they went through the whole process as
though they were doing a human uh amd
treatment the point being to check that
this thing is absolutely safe there's no
risk of something like cancer coming up
when you try and modify the genes inside
inside these cells in order to turn them
into you know back into cells to the
back of the eye and that seemed to pass
with flying colors so again there's just
it's a really big job i think getting
something um
particularly something biological you've
got to nail down so many different
things before you feel confident
sticking that into a human being but i
think those are the two that are
probably furthest ahead at the moment
cool and so you mentioned parkinson's
disease which is i guess in general uh
categorized as a neurodegenerative
disease and another really big
neurodegenerative disease associated
with aging as alzheimer's and in your
book you mentioned actually a couple of
examples where there's some really
exciting research um being categorized
to treat alzheimer's um as i was just
wondering could you elaborate on some of
those strategies
that's a really fascinating thing and i
i wonder if we're going to at least
partly cure alzheimer's or not cure but
defer alzheimer's i should say by
accident because i think that there's
been
obviously this enormous focus within the
alzheimer's field on one particular kind
of accumulated protein this stuff called
amyloid beta and for the last 20 maybe
30 years scientists um this is how
alzheimer's was actually first
identified with these these plaques and
tangles inside people's brains in
post-mortems and you know so it was
obviously thought that these
these things are obvious if you cut a
brain open perhaps this stuff there's an
obvious biological you know change that
you can see if you're a pathologist
maybe that's what's driving the disease
and so um and i mean the other thing
that really really motivated that
hypothesis in the 70s and 80s was the
discovery of people who've got what's
called early onset alzheimer's so that's
a form of the disease where you have a
particular genetic mutation in your
amyloid and sorry in your a beta
production which means you produce a lot
more of this amyloid and you can get
diagnosed with alzheimer's i think even
as early as your 30s but more typically
in your 50s and 60s which is a long time
before the age-related form of the
disease would normally kick in
so that's been a really really dominant
theory and we spent an awful lot of
research time trying to clear out this
amyloid beta to try and basically clear
out what seems to be waste um inside the
brain in order to try and sort out
dementia and although we got very very
good at clearing the amyloid
unfortunately that doesn't seem to have
translated to improvements in anything
about patient outcomes you know people
aren't getting cognitively better or
anything like that
so that's you know on the one hand as
biological success but a medical failure
so
um now there's just a whole plethora of
different strategies i think the failure
of this hypothesis and the conclusive
failure because so so many drugs have
failed to improve outcomes has meant
that a whole different range of
hypotheses are being explored and
actually i think a serious one is just
is looking at something like
inflammation this sort of increase in
inflammation as we go through our lives
and it's cellulase in essence again
appears to be at least somewhat
implicated in dementia i just think that
quite a lot of these other approaches
although dementia is certainly worth
studying in and of itself and trying to
uncover what exactly the causes are i
think that by improving all kinds of
things in our aging bodies and we're
talking about lysosomes earlier as well
you know improving the clearance of the
live effusion from inside lysosomes
which also seems to be a really
important factor in all
neurodegenerative conditions that we've
looked at um i don't really know what's
going to happen with alzheimer's i think
it's really up in the air at the moment
but i do feel like it's it's such a
disease of aging right so we already
said earlier that the risk of death
doubles every eight years or so in a
human being
uh
whereas dementia is actually even more
extreme than that your risk of dementia
is basically zero unless you've got one
of those early onset forms that i
mentioned earlier before the age of 60.
and then it doubles every four and a
half years after that so substantially
faster than the rate of aging it really
is an incredibly strongly age-associated
disease so hopefully by going after some
of the other hallmarks my sort of my
fingers are crossed that we're going to
at least defer dementia by doing that
cool that's really interesting um it's
another area of like um the field i find
quite interesting at the moment is like
more the personal approach and how
obviously we're all very different and
we're going to respond differently i
might need different therapeutics and
say one thing that i know kind of links
back to some of the work you did as a
computational biologist
is about um
using data and machine learning tools to
kind of predict the correct treatment
options and so i believe you did some
work looking at um electronic health
records
and being able to predict um the risk
associated with cardiovascular disease
and so i was just wondering if you could
explain more about what exactly it was
you were doing and how machine learning
approaches could be used to to help with
uh personalized therapeutics
yeah the idea of that project was um we
wanted to you know take advantage of
this enormous rich data set because in
the uk we're very fortunate to have the
nhs and that means that literally
everybody basically is on the same
medical records database and so we had
data from people's gps we had data from
hospital visits we had data on
operations that had had medications
they'd been given all this different
stuff
and what that had been used for in the
past
was to try and predict cardiovascular
outcomes like you say so um you know so
say you're a doctor you're starting your
doctor's surgery and someone comes in
and you're trying to decide whether to
prescribe them some preventative like
statins now statins are a drug that
obviously have side effects and so you
don't want to just be handing them out
like candy to everyone over a particular
age you want to be handing them out to
people who are actually at risk of
having a heart attack and so what you
like is a prognostic risk score they
call it so you know basically a score of
how likely are you to have a heart
attack in the next five years
and so the way those are traditionally
calculated is a bunch of nerds basically
get together a bunch of you know doctors
and epidemiologists and scientists and
they might look at this medical records
database and say okay we think these are
the 20 or 30 most important factors
some stats nerds then go away and turn
those factors into a model
and we say okay what this can do is this
model can show us with a certain degree
of accuracy what your likelihood of
having a heart attack is in the next
five years and then your gp when you
come in and um
and visit them rather than sort of
looking at your history and sort of
having to have a bit of a think and try
to base this entirely on their judgment
they can type your various scores or
like ideally they could take all the
blood test results it would
automatically move into this model and
it would then say okay your risk of a
heart attack in the next year uh in the
next five years is five percent and i
say okay my threshold for prescribing
statins is four percent so here are your
statins you know be on your way
and what we thought was there's just
this huge opportunity to put machine
learning into this situation because uh
these scientists uh the the the this
this model i just described in slightly
hypothetical terms have actually been
made by some clinicians and
epidemiologists and they were using i
think it was it was just over 30 of
these of these numbers but there are
literally hundreds maybe thousands of
different codes inside these medical
records and so you're just throwing away
so so much information by using these
expert models and the other thing we
wanted was you know not only could you
use more information more isn't always
better
because sometimes it can lead to
phenomena like overfitting where you
sort of get spuriously accurate results
that then don't generalize to the wider
population
not only could you have more of these
things you could also potentially
uncover things that the experts might
not have thought of
and so that's what we did we used a
variety of different techniques uh one
of them called elastic net regression
which if anyone's familiar with
epigenetic clocks it's actually the same
statistics that's used to derive those
and i also use something called random
forest which is just another statistical
technique to try and sift through these
hundreds and hundreds of variables and
come up with the best possible model
and um what i managed was well
few first of all we did slightly beat
the clinicians and epidemiologists that
was a little bit more accurate with all
that data
it wasn't sufficiently more accurate for
that to be like a huge huge success
because we beat them by you know a
fraction of a fraction of a tiny tiny
amount but what i thought was more
exciting was that we did all this
without having to understand anything
you know about cardiology i'm not a
cardiologist as you as you know i'm
trained as a physicist so i knew nothing
about hearts before we started that
project and yet completely naive
obviously the machine didn't know
anything about hearts either it could
pull out the variables that were most
important and some of those variables
did overlap with what the experts had
thought you know things like heart rate
and blood pressure obviously they're
important as to you know whether or not
you're going to have a heart attack but
we also pulled out some stuff that you
really wouldn't necessarily have
expected and i think my favorite example
of that was um something that's
prognostic of whether or not you're
going to have a heart attack is if
you've had a telephone consultation with
your gp now i guess
that variable might not work so well in
in the covert era because obviously all
of us if we want to interact with rgb
have to do it by telephone or certainly
encourage very strongly to do so but
back in those days having a telephone uh
encounter or even a home visit is sort
of the more extreme version of that if
your gp has to come to your house what
that means is you're probably so ill
that you can't make it to the surgery
and therefore um what that suggests is
that you know perhaps you're at higher
cardiovascular risk and so this is sort
of almost an administrative code that's
put in there it's nothing to do with the
patient's actual health or blood markers
or anything like that and yet we found
it was quite predictive
so what this allows you to do then is to
you know uncover these things that can
be useful that can help a prognostic
score but that wouldn't necessarily have
been thought of by experts and i think
what's most exciting about that is um as
i say my score didn't do vastly better
than that that the cardiologists already
had but the fact is that heart disease
is a very well characterized disease um
you know we we know a lot about the risk
factors uh if you get a doctor in the
room you know they'll immediately reel
off the 10 things they think are most
important it's fairly well understood
but the fact is you know building those
expert models firstly it requires that
understanding we just talked about
dementia you know we don't necessarily
have the understanding of the etiology
of some of these uh some of these other
diseases and secondly there are just
loads of diseases so if you want to do
this for some slightly more obscure
condition you know you might have to get
a bunch of experts together and it takes
the same amount of time to build this
hand-built expert model and yet it might
only apply to a far smaller fraction of
the population so it might just not be
worth doing economically or or whatever
so what's cool about the machine
learning is whatever the condition is
and whatever the state of the expert
understanding of it you can try and see
if the model can pull something out and
if it can then you potentially got a
prognostic tool for something you
otherwise wouldn't have been able to
have so that was what we were hoping to
do and yeah i think that's why that's so
exciting the question of whether it's
going to lead to personalized treatment
i think is a much thornier one because
the thing with prediction is you've got
quite good data and particularly
something like a heart attack or death
like it's very easy to find when someone
has one of those things it's quite
difficult you'd think to dodge you know
you're that appearing in your gp record
actually intriguingly one of the other
difficulties with using this it's called
sort of found data when you use a record
that already exists rather than a record
that was specifically created um i've
forgotten the numbers now but it's
remarkable so we had access to four
different databases there's the gp
records the hospital records a special
heart disease database and there was a
fourth one that i've forgotten right now
but there was it was quite shocking you
know a heart attack you think is very
major you can't fail to go to hospital
if you have a heart attack and your gp
cannot fail to receive a letter from the
hospital telling them that you've had a
heart attack if that happens and yet
there were still some huge percentage of
patients who weren't recorded in all
four of these data sources and it's just
as i say this is where the hazards of
using found data it's often got lots of
missing values and so it doesn't
necessarily have everything you want
nonetheless heart attacks death they're
quite um unambiguous outcomes shall we
say whereas if you're looking for
something a bit more subtle it can be a
bit more challenging and the particular
challenge with treatment is that
outside of the context of clinical
trials doctors normally prescribe the
best treatment for that particular
patient in their you know in their
estimation it's normally the treatment
is actually the first line treatment the
first on the list and then move to the
second one if that doesn't work for some
reason which often might not be that but
not not particularly clear so the
question is is there going to be a
diverse enough range of data in terms of
what treatments people were given in
order for the machine to learn and my
sort of dream for the future is firstly
that just machine learning techniques
generally will advance i think we're
already seeing that particularly neural
networks are really hot and exciting at
the moment but i guess you know these
techniques are evolving all the time and
getting better and better at digesting
and making sense of huger and huge
quantities of data but i think will be
really exciting and this is again
particularly applicable to a country
like the uk where we do have a national
health service and literally everybody
is enrolled into effectively the same
system
i'd like to see a lot more adaptive
clinical trials happening in a
healthcare setting so quite often you
know patients have complicated diseases
it's not necessarily 100 clear what the
absolute best drug for them would be and
in that case it would be nice if the
computer could randomize them to one of
a few relatively good options and then
you know over sort of months and years
they watch those patients afterwards you
can then draw that data together and as
it becomes clear that certain treatments
are better for certain types of patients
maybe you could increase the probability
that a patient with those
characteristics gets that treatment so
people are always getting or the the
largest percentage of people are always
getting the best possible treatment but
there's always a little bit of
experimentation going on in the system
as well just to make sure that what we
think is the best possible treatment is
the best possible treatment
the issue of course then is that's
really exciting and i think you know
firstly it's exciting to nerds like me
and secondly i think it probably would
save the most lives overall if it were
carefully implemented but the problem is
that clinicians and members of the
public i think um have this real
uncertainty about randomization in a
treatment context i think if you're
randomizing a trial then everyone's like
oh i understand why we're doing this
we've got to find out if one drugs
better than the other but by the time
you get to the clinic
you want everyone to be getting the same
treatment you don't want to feel like
you're missing out on the best treatment
and often that's um
in a sense slightly misguided because we
don't always know what the best
treatment is for a particular situation
but at the same time you know you don't
want to feel like you're the person
who's been randomized to placebo or you
know you're the person who's been
randomized to the second best treatment
because that's because that's what the
computer told you to do that makes it
feel even worse if there's not
necessarily a human making every aspect
of the decision so i think there's a lot
of exciting potential for that
um but it's just a question of you know
how can we implement those things in a
healthcare setting
yeah now that was really fascinating i
that was amazing detail um so in terms
of also the potential of using these
machine learning techniques what kind of
measurements do you think are going to
be most um necessary to have for example
like blood measurements or
even things like box office that seems
to also be important
um and i guess on from that what are
kind of like the major challenges
to also trying to use this approach more
globally i guess things such as security
of the data or um
actually
trying to pull data from different
sources
i think in answer to the first thing we
just don't know what are the most
important things and i i we can probably
make some reasonable guesses in terms of
you know doctors can obviously tell you
with more wisdom than i can what are you
know considered to be important blood
tests but at the same time you don't
necessarily want to always go with what
doctors think are the most important
things because you know i massively
respect doctors for the ridiculous
amount of knowledge they hold in their
heads about human bodies there have also
been a lot of times in the past and what
seems to be the medically obvious uh
particular answer has turned out not to
be correct at all so i think we have got
to sort of try and throw a bit of
randomness in there and sort of let the
machine learning models do their thing
um in terms of the data security yeah
that is a huge huge challenge but i
think that's definitely something we're
all waking up to not just in medicine
but in our everyday lives as well
because you know we've got facebook and
google and all these different companies
that are just basically their business
model is to aggregate as much data about
us as possible and that's really
starting to include health data as well
because google is starting to do work um
they've been doing machine learning and
medical records data as well because
it's clearly you know a huge huge
business opportunity as well as one for
improving human health um luckily i
think because there is that awareness we
are starting to get a bit better at this
and actually covid here in the uk has
driven some really big innovations in
this area there was a
sort of family of trials called open
safely and i think that's some tortured
acronym but i'm afraid i don't know what
for but the idea there was that um this
was this was actually as i say
specifically to look at covert they were
trying to find out which patients are at
highest risk um based on their medical
records based on you know hospital
admissions and who comes into hospital
with covert and so on and the way that
that system was set up was that
everybody's medical records were stored
on an entirely secure central database
and then if you wanted to analyze those
records then what you had to do was
submit a job which was then processed on
this central database and then it would
spit out the answers but you never
actually saw you know you never had your
hands on the actual data and so that's
just a really great model because then
what that means is that you know
researchers can effectively do this
thing do this kind of stuff almost
entirely anonymized
the real challenge is that actually
although we deal with anonymized data
it's sometimes called pseudonymized
because um you know you don't actually
it's very hard to truly anonymize stuff
so when you when you say pseudonymized
it might mean it doesn't have your name
it doesn't have your actual date of
birth you might round it to the nearest
month it doesn't have uh your nhs number
for example it's got some random
identifier that we then give you know
then give the patients
the problem is that even if you hand
over what seems like a really well
pseudonymized data set it's actually
remarkably easy to start de-anonymizing
people to certainly work out who these
individuals actually are
because if you think about you know the
number of unique characteristics we each
have obviously you know you've got your
gender even knowing your month of birth
is a good start knowing which part of
the country you live in you know you can
you can start to isolate people very
quickly particularly if they have a rare
condition or something like that you
might be able to identify them down to
just a handful of people in the uk just
because of one particular disease that
they've been diagnosed with so there are
definitely challenges there but i think
we're hopefully getting better and
better at navigating them so it's uh
yeah watch this space i guess
yeah that's really interesting and so
you mentioned elastic net regression
models that you use um for your studies
and how that's also used in epigenetic
clocks as i was just wondering if you
could first maybe comment on your
opinion on epigenetic clocks at the
moment and then maybe just discuss a bit
further like where else do you see the
use of maths in trying to treat agent
yeah i think um i actually think to
answer the second part of your question
first i think that biomarkers are one of
the most exciting places that maths and
machine learning can come to bear
because we do have all kinds of data
sets uh you know and i i think a really
cool example of this actually is just
just looking at people right so there's
this fascinating study that came out in
2009 where uh people were asked to rate
how old they thought other people looked
and what they found was that people who
are rated as looking older seem to
actually be biologically older than
their people you know other people the
same age who looked younger they got
more diseases they died more quickly and
so on and you know since then we sort of
tried to formalize that a little bit by
using machine learning you know take a
photo of someone's face and then the
computer will you know analyze the
various various things on the image and
obviously it being machine learning we
can never be quite 100 sure what it is
it's analyzing uh but it'll then spit
out a number that tells you how
biologically old you are based on that
and that's a really cool application
because rather than taking you know
loads of blood tests or doing a full
body mri scan or however else we could
get you know huge huge volumes of data
to put into these models you can just
take a photo and actually there was an
example of trying to do this for mice as
well and again you know if you're doing
a mouse experiment you can take all you
know you can measure the epigenetic age
and do all this you know complicated
blood tests or you can just take a
before and after picture and if you
could get that to work with sufficient
accuracy that's a huge huge improvement
so i think that's a really cool place
that we can use maths
in terms of the epigenetic clocks i
think it's sort of a case of waiting and
seeing unfortunately they're clearly
very good at predicting
the biological age of people who are
living in our current normal environment
but the problem with all machine
learning or a lot of machine learning is
it's often looking for correlations and
not what's actually causative so it
might be if i've got you know this
particular spectrum of values of blood
tests and that can then be used to
derive an epigenetic clock and that then
tells me that i'm this old
you know you see people trying to
optimize a particular blood test value
but that's kind of cheating because is
it that blood that blood test is
actually the thing that's driving your
aging or is it that whatever value it's
measuring actually you know is
indicative of a whole range of other
things going on in your body or that
value only makes sense in combination
with the other values that have been put
into the to the biological aging clock
that you're looking at and what i think
we really need to see to get properly
excited about this stuff
is if we do some therapies that we know
slow down the aging process and then the
epigenetic clock responds in a
commensurate way then we can say that
we're measuring something meaningful and
not just measuring you know some aspect
of the way that we currently live our
lives effectively and there are some
early signs that this work so we you see
that in animals that are undergoing
calorie restriction for example their
epigenetic clock seemed to take more
slowly and there was even this trial of
um thymus rejuvenation which showed that
people's epigenetic clocks were reduced
by i think it was a few months or maybe
a year after the treatment had been done
so
i think it's really exciting but it's
just a question of watching this space
and trying to find out
um yeah trying to try to find out if
these things actually do show us what we
need them to show us because at the
moment the ideal way to do a trial and
the way the tame metformin trial i
talked about earlier is going to be done
is they're going to give a bunch of
people i think it's between the ages of
60 and 79 metformin are a placebo and
they're going to watch them for a few
years
that trial has to be big because
ultimately even a 65 year old only has a
one percent chance of dying that year
and that means that you know in order to
actually see one 65 year old die you
need to have 165 year olds in your trial
and that means if you want to see a
difference between the treatment and
placebo armor of the trial you have to
have hundreds and hundreds of people
involved you have to watch them for
several years in order to get good
enough statistics to actually draw
conclusions whereas if we could do
epigenetic clock measurements for
example you could take a blood test from
everyone before the trial started you
could give them metformin for six months
and then every person in your trial is a
data point rather than just a handful
who died because everyone has an
epinephrine engaged before and they've
got an epidural they've got an
epigenetic age after if i can say that
and that means that everyone's a data
point so in a far shorter time with far
fewer participants potentially you can
come up with the same results and that's
obviously really important for for us as
agent researchers because we don't want
to be waiting you know 10 20 30 years
for the ultimate clinical trial to find
out if giving us analytics to 50 year
olds is something that's going to slow
down their aging it's far far more
useful if we can get results in you know
months or small numbers of years and the
smaller the number of participants you
can use the less expensive these trials
are so the more of them you can do in
parallel the more stuff we can try out
so i think it's really exciting it's
just a question of you know are they
going to work as we hope they're going
to work
yeah exactly
and so evidently you're very good at
communicating science and i believe now
that you do science communication as
kind of like your your full-time career
so i was just wondering if you could
maybe
talk about some projects that you're
working on or what is it you're you kind
of get up to on a daily basis besides
talking to people like me
yeah it's a good question it's a very
strange job this so i spent a lot of
time writing this book right so that's
the i was fortunate enough to get a book
deal um toward the end of my second
postdoc and basically decided to write
full time and i'm so glad i did because
it
effectively took me two years full time
to write the book and it's just because
aging biology is such a huge field
it obviously touches on every aspect of
biology and so it's not possible to be
an expert in all of those things before
you start and i certainly wasn't that
meant i had to talk to you know loads
and loads of scientists i had to read
loads and loads of papers and i wanted
to make it really really robust as a
book as well because um i've tried as
you sort of mentioned earlier um to make
it as accessible as possible to as many
people as possible but at the same time
and if you're a biology nerd and you're
thinking oh this all sounds a bit sci-fi
and kooky there are hundreds of
references in the back of the book where
you can chase up everything i've said
you know make sure that i'm not talking
total nonsense and it was really really
important to me that was as
scientifically robust as possible so it
couldn't just be dismissed out of hand
as some sort of fringy fringy theories
being passed around so that was the
first thing i've spent an awful lot of
time was just just writing the book
at the same time i've been trying to
make some youtube videos to talk about
various aspects of science not just
aging biology so i think it's really
important to try and engage people on a
variety of different cool scientific
things i mean i guess ultimately one of
the reasons why i want to live a longer
healthier life is to have more time to
explore this wonderful universe we find
ourselves in i'm still you know that
astronomy bug that i had back at the age
of seven hasn't entirely gone away
um i've also been writing articles for
newspapers and doing a lot of press are
often around the book um
and that's just been a really really
cool opportunity there's some talk of
maybe a tv series but these things are
totally totally unknown i've done a bit
of tv presenting on other things so it's
just a very strange sort of collection
of stuff i guess i'm starting to think
about a second book now so i guess we'll
just have to see
awesome that sounds really exciting and
i also i think i saw you on the russell
howard show recently which is also super
exciting
um yeah it's really cool that's
definitely a sort of childhood dream of
mine i've always been fascinated by
comedy so to be honest sort of comedy
news you know topical satire show is
absolutely fantastic and also what's
really cool about that is um i'm
genuinely passionate about getting the
message out about aging to as many
people as possible and so it's all about
you know going to these really
mainstream outlets be you know
mainstream news shows or comedy shows or
whatever it is and just telling them
about this stuff so it doesn't seem
fringe and weird you know it's obviously
i love talking to scientists you can
probably tell you know i'm happy to nerd
out about anything for any level of
detail but i think the thing that really
excites me is talking to people who
haven't necessarily been exposed to
these ideas at all before and showing
them this is mainstream exciting stuff
exactly um as i'm talking more about um
generally just aging and health in
general um and they'll see a lot of
these treatment options there isn't
enough data to uh talk about them or
implement them but in general what kind
of advice would you give to someone who
is trying to be more healthy
there's a health advice chapter in the
back of the book and i think it falls
kind of into two categories one of them
is the stuff you've probably heard a
hundred times before but i hope that
understanding a bit more about aging
biology will really encourage you to
stick to that advice and that's the sort
of a big part of the sort of my health
regimen has been driven by that in that
i knew that you're supposed to you know
not eat too much and try and eat a
balanced diet and try and get some
exercise and obviously not smoke is the
big thing that should be in you know red
flashing lights um that you really
really shouldn't do these things
the thing that really encourages me to
you know watch my diet a bit and try and
make sure i do get plenty of exercise is
that these things literally slow down
the aging process so if you think about
you know something like exercise it's
obvious when you exercise that you're
you know you can feel your heart beating
in your chest you can feel your lungs
going you can feel your muscles being
worked out it's clearly a cardiovascular
workout it's clearly helping your
muscles but as you understand more about
the biology you realize that it's going
to be you know decreasing inflammation
throughout your body it doesn't just
decrease the risk of heart disease which
is this obvious one it decreases the
risk of quite a few different kinds of
cancer even decreases the risk of
dementia so it really suggests that you
know again just like analytics in a way
you're intervening in a whole range of
different aspects of the aging process
and that makes that seem really really
cool to me
um the other thing that i find is that
there are some bits of health advice
that you just wouldn't expect but for
aging biology i think my favorite
example of that is uh trying to brush
your teeth so it's been noticed
throughout um throughout the last 10 20
30 years that people with worse oral
hygiene tend to go on to have uh worse
heart outcomes whereas cardiovascular
problems
and you might be sort of scratching your
head and thinking well this is another
example where correlation doesn't equal
causation because maybe it's the people
who have you know have more time to take
care of their teeth they have less tooth
decay they have less gum disease but
also they have more time to exercise
they have more time to you know cook
really good meals they have more time to
take care of their health generally and
so these two things are related but
they're not causally related but
actually as you start to unpick the
biology a bit more you realize this is
again a source of that chronic
inflammation that i've alluded to a few
times because you know in youth you have
this inflammatory process it's very very
important it's the way that your body
responds to external threats so if there
are bacteria in your mouth you'll get
inflammation your immune system will
rush your mouth and try and clear out
those bacteria the problem is of course
that your immune system can never quite
get rid of all those bacteria that's why
dentistry is in a way so archaic you
know because they literally drill bits
of your tooth out because there's no
other way to get rid of the bacteria um
so what happens is there's this sort of
constant fizzing going on inside your
mouth of of inflammation and so the
inflammation goes from acute which is
like turns on very rapidly when there's
a problem and turns off very rapidly
when that problem is finished to chronic
so it's sort of constantly going on it's
sort of a paranoia in your immune system
and we know that that can drive the
whole aging process and in fact that
seems to be the causal link between
having clean teeth and having a
well-functioning heart there's even some
evidence that again it could slow down
dementia so you know if there wasn't
enough um sort of incentive to avoid
dental bills and to avoid painful tooth
decay to keep your teeth cleaned you
know to floss and brush your teeth every
night as thoroughly as possible then i
think the fact that it can literally
slow down aging is something that's
really encouraged me to keep on top of
my dentistry
that's really good advice um i'd say
more generally do you have any advice
for those wanting to kind of get into
the field of aging biology obviously
you've had a kind of more unconventional
approach but do you have any yet just
general advice about having a scientific
career
i think it's just important to um sort
of
have your goal in mind it would be ideal
to have your goal in mind from the start
right don't do the physics phd but at
the same time don't feel constrained by
your qualifications so far or you know
whatever you are already you feel like
you've got expertise in because it is
possible to make these career switches
at any stage of your career you know
don't feel constrained by your a-levels
or your degree or your phd even because
you can make these changes whenever you
want and i think it's also important
just not to be disheartened because one
of the real challenges of aging biology
i sort of mentioned this earlier there
aren't that many labs doing it so it
might be that you can't find your
perfect master's project your perfect
phd working you know in exactly the
group that you wanted studying exactly
the aspect of the aging process you
wanted but the fact is a lot of the
knowledge that you acquire you know
maybe as i said i wouldn't recommend a
physics phd but if you go and do some
research in an excellent cancer research
lab and you learn loads of lab
techniques and you learn you know
pipetting and
molecular biology of which i cannot
possibly going because i've never worked
in a biology lab but all all those
techniques are incredibly
cross-applicable if you become an expert
in a certain particular kind of
microscopy then that microscopy is
probably going to be applicable to the
aging process as well so by the time you
get to the level where you're applying
for your own funding you can start to
move your research you know sort of
segue into that direction which means
you could perhaps carry on doing
whatever your core expertise is and you
know make sure you can keep on churning
out those papers which is so important
for your academic career but at the same
time start to redirect a bit of your
energy towards aging biology
so basically
i think just keep your head down and
carry on as best as possible if you can
get a position doing directly working on
exactly what you want from the beginning
that's great but if you can't just press
on you know keep gathering expertise and
eventually you'll probably be able to
find a way to apply that expertise to
aging
yeah exactly um so where can people go
to find out more information about you
and the work that you do
so you can check out the book at
ageless.link um i've got a website
andrew steele.com k i'm also a lot on
twitter which is at stato um my youtube
channel is dr andrew steele like to keep
all these things different just to keep
everyone on their toes and i'm on a
variety of other social media stuff as
well if you just search for me you'll
find me there okay great i'll put some
of those links into the description as
well so yeah andrew it's been great to
have you on today um i think we've
covered like so many different uh topics
and it's been really informative so yeah
just thank you very much for the work
that you're doing
thank you so much for having me it's
been a lot of fun
thank you
so i hope you've learned something in
this video
thank you to my patreon supporters and
thank you for listening
you